une infirmière sur le banc des accusés
une situation que dénonce la cgt et le
groupe solidaire il estime que ce n'est
pas la place de farida l'infirmière
cadre de santé à l'hôpital de villejuif
aujourd'hui on sanctionne totalement
farida et on appelle à ce que la justice
ne la convainquent pas je crois que
c'est aujourd'hui un procès à faire
cesser le procès de la violence sociale
c'est le procès de cette politique macro
niel voilà qui détruit tout sur son
passage
les services publics le 16 juin 2020
farida visage en sang a violemment été
interpellé par les forces de l'ordre
lors d'une manifestation de soignants à
paris traîneau sol est tirée par les
cheveux sur l'esplanade des invalides
mais interpellation qui avait ému
l'opinion publique
en plein débat sur les violences
policières et provoqué la colère de
l'opposition
quel que soit votre statut de
manifestants ou votre style de
manifestants rouges et ils m'ont dit
sourit lacrymogènes dans un contexte qui
ont chacun sait que si vous êtes en plus
fatigué épuisé
on peut y avoir des gestes des gestes
donc pas lieu d'être mais tout ça ne
vaut pas de se retrouver tiré par les
cheveux tout s'insurge vous pas de se
retrouver mais le noter tout ça ne vaut
pas de se retrouver au tribunal
le gouvernement qui devrait au tribunal
aujourd'hui pour avoir placé les
soignants comme farida dans la situation
ils ont été face aux collines
quelques minutes plus tôt l'infirmière
de 51 ans avait été filmée jetant des
pierres sur les forces de l'ordre et
faisant des doigts d'honneur
elle reconnaît les faits mais précise
que sa colère est dirigée contre l'état
et non contre les policiers
farida pointe du doigt les conditions de
travail dans les hôpitaux publics et les
failles du système de santé
je suis vert pour les malades qui ne
peut plus être soignées comme le souhait
hôpital ça concerne tout le monde
donc si on continue à ce rythme là on ne
fera plus rare soignés dans les hôpitaux
coup
merci beaucoup son avocat précise que
l'enjeu aujourd'hui n'est pas de savoir
ce qui a été fait mais pourquoi donc
j'ai aujourd'hui ça n'est pas
véritablement de savoir ce qui a été
fait mais c'est de savoir pourquoi ça a
été fait et ce pour quoi c'est
l'indignité à l'indignité de les
gouvernements successifs et notamment du
gouvernement d' emmanuel macron l'égard
de l'hôpital à l'égard des soignants à
l'égard des patients pendant la période
de la pandémie mais même avant la
période de lock d'aborder me aujourd'hui
on à 57% de soignants dans l'hôpital
public qui souffre de syndrome
post-traumatique on à 41 % au minimum de
soignants qui souffrent de burn out
les syndicats de police dénoncent eux
une attitude très grave ils veulent une
sanction pour couper court à tout
sentiment d'impunité
il relève la difficulté d'une
interpellation lors d'une manifestation
tout acte délictuel doit être sanctionné
il faut procéder à une interpellation
on ne cherche pas à comprendre c'est une
infirmière que l'on va interférer ou
quelle que soit sa profession suis con à
la d'appel ce sont des individus qui
commettent des attractions d'aidé et
pour ce qui est des black blocks que
vous faites référence c'est extrêmement
difficile de réussir des interpellations
et c'est notamment pour ça qu'on insiste
sur l'importance qui vient ce que d
autres participants aux manifestations
ou cède pas à la tentation des violences
car si en se laissant entraîner dans ces
phénomènes de violence qui sont
banalisés par la manifestation que l'on
rend plus difficile le travail des
forces de l'anp farida risque trois ans
d'emprisonnement et 45000 euros d'amendé
pour outrage rébellion et violences sur
personne dépositaire de l'autorité
publique